Nicolas HULLOT lui s'est retiré de la
course vous le savez mais il a fait le
plein ce matin la plupart des candidats
ont répondu à son invitation et sont
venus soutenir son Pact écologique ils
ont bien veillé toutefois à se présenter
un par un pour éviter les photos de
groupe Alexandre Cara Dominique
Bonet Nicolas HULLOT devant son trophée
les 10 signatures des candidats à la
présidentielle qui ont approuvé son Pact
écologique ça fait Chud au cœur et
plaisir de vous retrouver l'ex possible
candidat a organisé aujourd'hui un grand
oral aux allures de show télévisé
première à être convoqué la candidate
socialiste le développement durable
n'est pas un slogan électoral il est un
projet alternatif de
civilisation petits et grands candidats
traités sur un pied d'égalité 15 minutes
chacun mais certains ont moyennement
apprécié cet exercice
imposé si par moment il y avait un
dialogue entre les candidats ça va
exister est
jterand d'autres persuad de le
légitimité dout de la conversion
opportune de certains de leur Rivau nous
sommes pas DUP je
crois certains candidats ont signé d'un
CC sans prendre la mesure des défis
auquel nous sommes confrontés pour
conclure Nicolas S déci à faire entendre
sa
différencecol pas demandz pour obtenir
il suffit pas que vous disiez pour
convaincre c'est un dialogue c'est un
échange c'est un respect mutuel vous
avez vos préoccupations votre expérience
j'ai la mienne j'ai le devoir de parler
aussi à des millions de français tous
candidats tous écolot comme si désormais
seule la pression médiatique pouvait
influer sur les priorités politiques t